is the geforce rtx 3060 any good what
should it cost and what does it really
cost also we'll be checking out ray
tracing and dlss performance and of
course we'll see how much better it is
than previous generation products so
let's get into it
[Music]
welcome back to harvard unboxed today i
am finally checking out nvidia's new
geforce rtx 3060. it was officially
released about two weeks ago now but i
was taking a break with my family and a
delay on nvidia's m with the driver due
to the unfortunate circumstances in
texas meant that i wasn't able to
complete my review before i left on the
plus side though this has allowed us to
take a more accurate look at pricing and
availability but of course we will have
all the usual array of benchmarks to go
over and i'll jump into that in a moment
before that though let's quickly talk
about the geforce rtx 3060 the new 330
us offering from nvidia but of course
you're unlikely to find it at that price
anytime soon due to the ongoing global
pandemic trade war and cryptocurrency
mining boom so yeah we're kind of
dealing with some stuff right now
the 30 60 is based on the new ga106 die
which measures 300 millimeters squared
and packs
3584 cores 112 tmus and 48 rops
now that's 26 fewer cores and tmus than
the ti version but 40 percent fewer rops
due to the downgrade from a 256 bit wide
memory bus to 192 bit wide
helping to minimize that reduction is
higher clocked 15 gigabits per second
gddr6 memory which provides a peak
bandwidth of 360 gigabytes per second so
just a 20 reduction from what we get
with the 3060 ti
now this change to the memory subsystem
meant that nvidia couldn't pair the rtx
3060 with eight gigabytes of vram like
what they did with the rtx 360 ti and
3070 for example
instead the options were essentially 6
gigabytes or 12 gigabytes of memory and
6 gigabytes would have been embarrassing
at this price point and with amd set to
release their mid-range parts with 12
gigabytes nvidia really had little
choice
it does also help them market the rtx
3060 and justify the 330 us asking price
which sees it come in just 18 cheaper
than the ti version despite a
significant reduction to the core
configuration
on paper the rtx 3060 doesn't appear to
be a great value product assuming that
all models sold at the msrp
but will of course conduct a full
performance evaluation and then work out
where it lands in terms of cost per
frame
for testing i'm still using my ryzen 9
3950x test system and i am still in the
process of updating to the 5950x so you
can expect all that data once we get
through this latest round of product
releases the system is also configured
with 32 gigabytes of dual rank dual
channel ddr4 3200 cl 14 memory
finally we'll only be looking at the
1080p and 1440p data for half a dozen of
the games tested though i have tested 14
in total and we will jump into the usual
performance breakdown graphs for all of
that data though please note if you want
to see any of the games that we didn't
look at they are available to float
plane and patreon members okay let's get
into the results
starting with the 1080p watchdogs legion
data we see the rtx 3060 was good for
just 61 fps on average making it
slightly slower than the previous
generation radeon rx 5700 xt which is
very disappointing to see in an nvidia
sponsored title
we're basically looking at rtx 2070 like
performance here so 500 us gpu
performance from three years ago
the margins are fairly similar at 1440p
at least relative to other geforce gpus
such as the rtx 2070 the 3060 does
manage to match the 5700 xt here so
that's certainly an improvement of what
we saw at 1080p but it's still 21 slower
than the 3060 ti
assassin's creed valhalla is an amd
sponsored title and here the 5700 xt was
well ahead of the rtx 3060 delivering 22
percent more frames and again the 3060
was only comparable to the rtx 2070 and
eight percent slower than the 2070 super
refresh then relative to the 3060 ti it
does well enough just a 13 deficit here
though we are only at 1080p
that said the margin remained much the
same at 1440p here the 360 was just 14
slot on the 360 ti and 15 slow on the
5700 xt it did match the vanilla rx 5700
and that meant it was just a few frames
faster than the rtx 2070
the rtx 3060 like most modern gpus
performed very well in death stranding
at 1080p hitting 129 fps on average to
match the gtx 1080 ti and rx 5700
that said it was 11 slower than the 5700
xt and 19 slower than the 3060 ti
the 1440p data for the most part is much
of the same 10 slower than the 5700 xt
though it was now 20 slower than the 360
ti it again matched the rx 5700 and that
meant it was nine percent faster than
the rtx 2070
you can play microsoft flight simulator
2020 at 1080p maxed out with an rtx 3060
though you are only looking at
performance that's equivalent to the rtx
2060 super rtx 2070 or rx 5700 with 40
fps on average
then at 1440p it does roughly match the
5700 xt and rtx 2070 with 32 fps on
average which is just playable here in
my opinion certainly not playable for a
shooter style game but for this
simulator it does work
moving on we have shadow of the tomb
raider and here the rtx 3060 rendered
120 fps on average at 1080p which saw it
basically match the 5700 xt to come in
21 slower than the 3060 ti
when compared to the previous generation
base model rtx 2060 which came in at a
similar price the 30 60 was 18 faster
then at 1440p we dropped down to what is
still a highly playable 83fps and again
the rtx 3060 is seeing matching the 5700
xt making it 23 slower than the 3060 ti
the last game we're going to look at is
tom clancy's rainbow six siege and at
1080p we see that the rtx 3060 was good
for
292 fps which made it a little bit
faster than the 2070 super and placed it
roughly on par with the rtx 2080 and
5700 xt so less impressive when compared
to the previous generation amd gpu
still it was 12 faster than the
similarly priced rx 5700
though that's not exactly huge progress
again we find that the 1440p data is
quite similar to what we saw at 1080p
the rtx 3060 is roughly on path the 2070
super and 5700 xt making it marginally
faster than the vanilla 5700 but 21
slower than the 3060 ti
okay so here's a look at the 1080p 14
game average data and here we see the
rtx 3060 is just six percent fast on the
rx 5700 on average so in terms of
progress that kind of sucks given the
msrp is just six percent lower
that means when compared to the
two-year-old amd gpu you're getting on
average six percent more performance for
what should be a six percent price
saving so not exactly amazing stuff
there
and when compared to nvidia's own
previous offerings the 3060 looks a bit
more impressive offering 15 more
performance than the 2 year old 2060
super while costing 8 percent less
of course turing was never particularly
great value but looking exclusively at
nvidia products the 3060 is quite good
and the 1440p data really does tell a
similar story here the rtx 3060 was on
average eight percent faster than the rx
5700 and five percent slower than the xt
model and this time it was 17 faster
than the 2060 super and 22 slower than
the 3060 ti
now here's a look at the controversial
msrp based cost per frame data and i
should note that there are rtx 3060s
listed for 330 us over at places like
newegg.com but whether or not you'll
ever be able to get stock for those
models is hard to say there's certainly
no stock right now and i suppose no
surprises there
when compared to the amd situation
though it does look better for example
the rx 6800 which has an msrp of 580. us
sees the cheapest model over at
newegg.com listed at 680 us with most
priced well over 700
and again all of them are out of stock
it is possible that the msrp prices for
the geforce cards over on newegg.com is
employed by nvidia to claim at the msrp
forcing aibs to advertise base model
cards while never actually stocking them
though we're not sure that theory is
correct given that we have heard from
people who managed to snap up an rtx
3070 and say a 3080 model at the msrp
from places like newegg.com
but whatever the case supply of those
models is even more limited and quite
clearly for the vast majority of
shoppers the msrp means nothing
still for future viewers or just those
of you who are interested in how the rtx
3060 stacks up at the claimed msrp let's
quickly go over that data before looking
at more realistic pricing at 330 us the
rtx 3060 is slightly worse value than
the 360 ti in terms of cost per frame
coming in at a six percent premium given
the 360 ti is 12 better value than the
37 you'd expect the 3060 to cost no more
than 280 u.s so 50 u.s less than the
actual msrp
when compared to previous generation
products such as the radeon rx 5700 xt
the rtx 3060 is just a 14 improvement in
cost per frame
so that's not terribly great progress
after two years
so at the time of making this video
major pc parts retailers such as newegg
didn't have a single rtx 3080 3070 3060
ti or 360 in stock and even the part
bundles where you have to buy a
motherboard memory were also out of
stock and that means if you want to buy
a card right now your best bet is to pay
scalper prices over ebay something we
strongly recommend you resist doing
but what we're looking at here is the
average sale price of completed listings
for products over the past week at ebay
i have manually gathered this data and
any dodgy listings like 500 rtx 3090s
for example were ignored
of this bunch the cheapest model was the
geforce rtx 2060 for 505 dollars us on
average roughly a 45 increase over the
msrp resulting in a cost per frame of
eight dollars and one cent when it
should be five dollars and fifty five
cents as for the rtx 3060 it comes in at
nine dollars and forty four cents per
frame and while that does make it the
cheapest of the geforce 30 series it was
only a percent cheaper than the rtx 37t
this data though really is meaningless
as the average sale price for the rtx
3060 was
793 us a 140
markup over the msrp
certainly no one should pay that for an
rtx 3060 but that's the pricing
situation now for models that are more
readily available
before wrapping up the benchmark graphs
we still have to take a quick look at
ray tracing and dlss performance along
with power consumption overclocking
stuff like thermal performance will come
via individual aib card reviews because
obviously that information will vary
depending on which model we're looking
at now for the rt and dlss testing
please note i'm using the second highest
quality preset for the three games
tested so not the maximum in-game
quality settings i'm also only testing
at 1440p as tim and i agree that 1080p
is for 200 us gpus especially when
prioritizing visual quality over high
frame rates
so in watchdog's legion at 1440p the rtx
3060 was good for just 62 fps on average
at the native resolution enabling
quality dlss boosted the frame rate by
30 to 81 fps so a very nice performance
upgrade there
now with medium quality ray tracing
enabled in conjunction with dlss the
frame rate dropped below 60 fps to 54
fps on average not amazing but certainly
still playable
then with the ultra quality ray tracing
the frame rate dropped to 49 fps again
not great but the game was still
playable depending on your requirements
now without the aid of dlss the game was
unplayable using ray tracing on the rtx
3060 at 1440p as frame rates dropped
well below 40 fps at least that's what i
deem unplayable in a game like
watchdog's legion
now when compared to the rtx 2060 the
3060 was 13 faster when comparing
rasterization performance with and
without dlss enabled however with ray
tracing enabled the 3060 was much more
efficient delivering up to 26 better
performance
and the inclusion of the rx 6800 also
shows just how poorly amd's rdna 2 gpus
perform with ray tracing enabled at
least in these nvidia optimized titles
here the rx 6800 was 65 faster than the
rtx 3060 without raytracing enabled but
with it enabled the radeon gpu was just
31 faster and 16 faster with the ultra
quality rt settings
shut off the tomb raider only uses ray
tracing for shadows and dlss doesn't
work nearly as well in this title
offering almost no performance uplift
without ray tracing enabled this time
the rtx 3060 was 16 to 20 fast in the
2060 with ray tracing enabled while it
was just 11 faster for straight
rasterization performance
the performance uplift offered by dlss
in control is massive here the rtx 3060
was 61 faster with dlss enabled and this
meant medium quality ray tracing with
dlss was able to match native resolution
performance though do keep in mind we're
only testing the game using the medium
quality preset when compared to the rtx
2060 the 3060 was 25 faster for
rasterization performance and we saw
similar margins with ray tracing and
dlss enabled
when it comes to power consumption the
rtx 3060 isn't particularly impressive
using only slightly less power the rtx
3060 ti at least that was the case for
our gigabyte rtx 3060 eagle model that i
use for testing when compared to the rtx
360 ti we're only looking at a 2
reduction in total system usage now
here's a better look at graphics card
power consumption using pcat here we
find the rtx 3060 does consume 12
percent less power than the 360 ti model
but given it was an average 22 percent
slower that's not a good result for
power efficiency it is a little more
efficient than the 2060 super for
example consuming six percent more power
for 17 more performance than average so
it is an improvement but not really an
amazing improvement
now here's a very brief look at
overclocking the gigabyte eagle
overclocked from the stock boost
frequency of 177 megahertz up to
1997 megahertz which resulted in a
sustained game clock speed of 2.1
gigahertz the memory also overclocked
from the stock 15 gigabits per second
transfer speed to 17.2 gigabits per
second and this manual overclock
improved performance and shot of the
tomb raider by 10
taking the average frame rate from 83
fps up to 91 fps basically 2070 super
performance in this title that's a
pretty typical ampere overclock so
nothing really unexpected here okay so
now at the conclusion of my review so
what do i make of the rtx 3060
i think if it were more normal times as
in you could actually buy a graphics
card at or very near the msrp the rtx
3060 would be a bit of a flop it really
doesn't bring anything new to the table
it's technically worse value than the
part above at the 30 60 ti and yet does
pack a bit more vram but at this price
point i think eight gigabytes is still
enough at least for now
but vram aside the rtx 3060 really has
very little going for it again assuming
the msrp is met for rtx 2060 owners it's
a very small upgrade and it's almost a
side grade for 2060 super owners while
it's a downgrade for anyone with a 5700
xt
if you're coming as far back as pascal
and owner gtx 1060 or even a 1070 the
rtx 3060 is a decent upgrade in terms of
performance but you'd be far better off
spending a little bit more money on the
ti version or waiting to see what amd
does at this price point but don't get
me wrong the rtx 3060 certainly isn't a
bad product it's technically very good
it's just the price that's a letdown
here ideally in my opinion it needs to
be at least 50 us less but that also
brings us to the current market
situation it's quite obvious that right
now nvidia sees a little point in making
the rtx 3060 a good value product the
kind of product it should and would need
to be during more normal times
it really can represent very poor value
right now nvidia will still be able to
sell as many of them as they can produce
evidenced by the fact that it sold out
instantly
even if the market was to return to
normality later this year something
we're not expecting by the way nvidia
can simply refresh the 360 series with a
super variant and adjust pricing to
whatever's appropriate at the time
so yeah the rtx 3060
it kind of sucks in terms of value
but it also doesn't matter right now as
gamers and miners are going to fight
over whatever stock is available
at this point i don't really expect
nvidia or amd to release any good value
gpus especially while the demand remains
exceedingly high and i suspect we're
probably going to go a little bit
further backwards before things start to
improve and that's going to do it for my
review sorry for the delay in getting
this content out unfortunately the
timing just didn't work out for us but
things will be returning to normal and
will be on top of all the other product
launches also harvard unboxed has two
new cats kittens even
you want to sit still there they're just
looking around they haven't been in here
before but anyway my daughters each got
a cat apparently cats are something that
tech channels have to have
so two new kittens i'll probably do some
bts videos for the float plane and
patreon members so you can get to know
these guys and keep an eye on their
progress but anyway they want to play at
the moment so i'll let them go do that
anyway something random so gamers nexus
has cats tim has a cat now i've got two
cats so i think that means i am winning
not sure on that one anyway yeah we do
have float plane patreon if you want to
get more involved with the channel
discord chat
uh live streams q and a's all that kind
of stuff that they're starting to pull
things apart anyway i probably should
wrap this one up thanks for watching i'm
your host steve and i'll see you again
next time
say hello hub viewers
i just want to pull things apart and
explore
[Music]
you